what's up guys how are you guys doing
gonna hit live and think idea yeah
sake okay we're live I think for life
huh let's see here let me just make sure
it's looking good all systems go
we're hearing the music excellent oh
yeah there we go good morning everyone
welcome back to GameSpot live
I'm Ritchie I'm here with Max yes I have
not streamed with max we go back meme
yeah I know it's been a while how you
doing man I'm friend pretty good good
good thank you for joining us today
yeah so we're gonna be playing a
Dragonball Z Kakarot with you heard and
read correctly off from CJ's dcj oh my
god
so this was a mod actually let me back
up here oh we don't have the window up
anymore you know what let's just get
right into it we're in the middle of the
piccolo fight and let's just you're
gonna see for yourself how it's going
down we're starting the very beginning
the game here because I don't think in
this PC mod we have any safe follows
that are actually pretty far so we're
sorry for the beginning that's okay CJ
started from the beginning yeah oh [ __ ]
here we go again
here we could just no no bike this time
just straight to the piccolo fight how
we doing chat good morning got a lot of
hello hello hi Tina Palace is finally a
true fighter that's what I'm talking
about
there you go I wish me and Max were
talking about it a little bit this
morning that's the boy samples were
thrown in that have been due yeah he has
a ton of voice samples as you guys know
any fans of CJ in here know that smooth
[Laughter]
Randy Hernandes welcome back thank you
guys all for being here yeah this is
exactly what it sounds like there is a
mod to replace Goku with CJ from GTA san
andreas you're looking at it y'all you
do you see here sure Johnny tsunami in
the chat says aw [ __ ] here we go again
exactly working his way up this is the
very first fight in the game and Max is
back max can hold it down
I'm already doing this kind of work
[Music]
that's right yeah that's true we opened
up the game and started the cutscenes
and they they are not they don't replace
EJ but uh the gameplays looking good
though real good savage says what am I
looking at boy you read the caption you
read the title you know exactly what
you're looking at
CJ's first fight on the streets we just
call him Big Smoke vixen does he's on
our side sort of that would take a lot
more work yeah rendered stuff yeah it's
still pretty it is it's great oh I'm
gonna have little son gohan Oh
oh [ __ ] I'd even think of that as little
Papa CJ here yep
you know I haven't watched that many CJ
mods but like watching the Resident Evil
2 remake oh yeah CJ was that was great
that was one of my favorites yeah oh my
gosh he actually had the voice lines too
yeah they did yeah that was so good oh
you know what the video yeah um I forget
well max and I were on the Facebook team
back in the day making memes yeah and I
think I might have added voice to that
one or you know wasn't I think I picked
the funny ones that I wanted to add good
time well it was so good yeah he's
calling like mr. eggs like I forgot he's
salting just skip this just go straight
back to CJ cuz like go for it man yeah
we've been here before
yeah we already been here before a lot
of people play this game already yeah
chat wants to see more seed yeah we want
to see more CJ I want to see Andrew in
the chat says I want to see CJ as a
Super Saiyan oh man like super like oh
it's gonna be a second till we get to
see Super Saiyan CJ though that's not
it's like all it was like yeah oh my god
young melee should come back in the
studio and just reread Goku's lines just
to make this complete yeah this is great
the poly difference between them - Grim
Reaper the chest is you picked the wrong
planet food it's so funny because how
different the character is like how
different OJ's character is than like a
game yeah positive
yeah like the start of GTA san andreas
CJ loses his mom he's bitter about
coming back to life meanwhile the
beginning of this game folk who's like
spending quality time with his son
fishing getting food for chichi
like it's it's jari this is no race not
normal CJ that's life is asking can we
get a jet pack I mean you got one
built-in now you're a flying saying can
I just do a little quick quick cheat and
popping uh are you gonna get double CJ
Oh remember for a while you show me that
bug or there's two Goku's if you run
away from yeah is that still around
maybe that works get to CJ's okay I
wonder if they ever patch that out you
flicked up for a second I was like I
love that stance he's like he's like
squared up ready to fight oh here we go
Oh all that in-game tutorial oh I don't
know
oh dang is too fast there we go
okay boom in the chat says CJ is 200 P
for this game we know it man that's why
they had to add them in let's wreck this
game that's fine though Jonah Jonah in
the Chad's like oh [ __ ] here we go again
every time he sees a villain yep follow
the damn train yes you guys definitely
just get it damn marker CJ catch the
damn fish DJ all you had to do was catch
the damn fish are they gonna like pull
that oh my god you know what I'm worried
about right now it was the fishing cuz
yet till I put a tail on himself oh yeah
I wonder if that's been like it's not
gonna actually probably not he's gonna
be like crouched over yeah like but
first in the water but with no tail
there's probably gonna be a lot of
hiccups but I'm here for it let's you
yes great that's that's the beauty of
the mods it is it's gonna be funny
little son gohan here zem ask is this a
true story yes this is DBZ canon
I remember oh you're gonna get that all
right yeah fine yeah no problem
I can leave 50 like 50 feet in the air
littering in and out yeah hang in there
chats gonna it's worth it
phasing in and out of existence yeah
like real Goku's like like trying to
come back I really want to see CJ with
Super Saiyan hey what what they do I
wonder there's gonna be like that outer
glow for sure but you know what they're
gonna do with the hair if it's really
crapoly added on I'm so ready
all right let me let me see if is old
model is there yeah sometimes they
patched it out
no double CJ no double goku rats that's
all right I'll run right back to my son
hello fans already crying yes any run to
lose my son oh no bad dad okay I was
gonna say respect - mm sorry son it's
okay we try to check something out logo
on we're back pick it up son pick it up
son dad literally have to like do like
micro steps here oh my gosh oh yeah just
like yeah it's funny he becomes so much
powerful later on like yeah funny team
as a child like pretty useless yeah oh
my god I miss Gohan and the cell saga he
looks so cool back then is that when he
turned super saiyan yeah you turned
super saying a little bit earlier but I
think it's the long ponytail later on
that's cool look yeah or like he wears
like the sane armor for that one season
yeah I look how they like just kept
changing armors throughout the seat
that's August yeah and yeah
okay all right been in the chat oh shoot
there he goes Oh No okay I hate this all
right there he goes okay be a good dad
CJ I didn't go Hans just ghost riding
the whip right now
Ben Ben joined us in the chase all you
had to do with all of the damn
Dragonball speed a very good I'm here
for CJ fish oh we can't wait to see how
this goes down
[Laughter]
Gohan is freaking out a little bit I see
it in his face but so are we we don't
know what's going on oh man Vegeta is
Ryder please that'd be dope or smoke
smoke yeah it was the whole gang we're
incorporating I know it's a lot of work
to make mods yeah all the characters
there it is that stance again he squared
up the [ __ ] fish yeah there's an
ammunition around the corner you still
don't get it go on yep is that like a
rat tail I think you can get that at the
barbershop I don't know I always kept it
like that I like the classic look or
maybe a hat but I never I never really
messed with the hair so much I just love
how you can go into the barber and like
have like this much hair yeah and come
out with like an app that makes a lot of
sense right
all right here we go well bowfishing
CJ's gonna spawn in the Rhino sets
oh my god I love that
[Laughter]
that's dinner for the whole hood right
there man it looks like an error though
too much oh my god this is great I'm so
glad that worked out so smoothly yeah
yeah pulled out a tail I don't know
where oh my god the chats like yeah the
hot coffee mod no no no no yeah I
learned that after that happened it was
recalled from the stores and then they
printed adult-only version you know the
radio they did that for a while oh
really
yeah until they until was completely
patched go for man it was so good for
anyone who's just joining us we're
playing as CJ clearly from grand theft
auto san andreas it takes the place of
Goku in Dragon Ball Z Kakarot and it's
going swimming come on they're running
away there you go yeah
get over here follow the damn ball CJ
yeah keep them coming we love CJ Tokio
damn
nice cool alright sick I've got a couple
fish oops I have to do what let go punch
the deer right over here is that really
an option in the regular game oh yeah
you can but it doesn't me cross the
bridge right oh alright well I'm
definitely doing that so they don't play
often many of the cutscenes like the
in-game cutscenes like that sure but for
those of you who are just joining they
don't play into the regular full-blown
cinematic cutscenes yeah that's okay
though
it's a lot harder to do I'm sure yeah
because already pre-rendered with Goku
in them yeah this stuff word you can
have Goku's model in it great oh man I
hope the modding community just adds the
whole crew and we can play we can play
Kakarot as like with all those GTA
characters let's see there are no kids
in GTA like ever I don't know they make
a point of that because I think it'd be
like it crossed some like legality line
yeah that make sense
I don't know he's a new kid he's the new
kid is ready to fight his son Oh that'd
be funny a little CJ coin yeah emblem
good there we go alright cool
bonding time with Gohan check community
with smoke yeah big smoke
what's the sisters name I forgot
everybody I'm gonna try to speed through
this weekend yeah that's your pretty
cool they have like new
[Laughter]
thanks Gohan Thanks look at the jab
mission pass respectfully we got to play
that that's perfect all right myself all
right sue cool cRIO smells very good
Jeremy says looks hilarious yep thank
you for joining us
chat it out in the chat where you guys
from
I love to hear it you know every day
tells where you're from and tell us what
time it is where you're from
Bree what time you guys watching yeah I
don't want to hear any comments like
well I'm at work you better not be
viewing better not be at work know that
yes you Scott see that's okay
all right we're gonna go skip these
portions yeah we're gonna get straight
back into the gameplay portions why does
this exist why not look at this are you
asking me that for real cuz everyone
loves CJ bottom lines go odds going away
I don't feel so good just follow the
damn orb CJ yes right this is the Train
mission yeah this is the Train mission
he's on he's on the bicycle or the
Nimbus right now
[Laughter]
there we go oh my god yeah in that one
in that one season we're like Goku dies
for a little before they wish him back
yeah this is what happens yeah chichi
just marry CJ all we got some love from
South Africa it's 9:00 p.m. over there
Hawaii time 9:18 a.m. nice and early so
quality that India 1250 am I love to do
that every time well if I remember on
Chatham I always like to shout it out
like show show some love from where
you're from you know yeah we're here as
you guys know in the San Francisco
office it is 11 19 am in sunny
California hell yeah Oh full course meal
we don't think we have the degrees CJ
can hang he can do he need all the food
yeah that posed yeah oh my god they put
him in all these funny ass poses that
Goku's normally standing in it's so it's
not even that funny it's just like he's
like stand-up much more differently it
would be in actual San Andreas alright
that's some love from hungry alright
that's so cool what's up guys oh you had
to do was follow the damn train yes we
have a lot of San Andreas fans in the
house today from San Antonio Texas
Dominique welcome in Texas where it's a
1:20 p.m. a Shrek mod please that would
be great so my god has to be that
sloppiness
one thing at a time y'all we were lucky
to find this although I saw something I
forget what website posted an article
about it where they had also the anger
boost
thrown into this game over as well as CJ
his neck was all my oh my gosh is neck
is like not you might want to have that
looked at bro
wait to go to a chiropractor in
alabaster can CJ turn Super Saiyan we
cannot wait to see that we don't know if
we can get there today but we're gonna
try cuz we started from the beginning of
the game but we have that same question
friend because we don't get to see well
we can see kaio-ken zj possibly it's
gonna be a walk away see Super Saiyan
Chi joke I says Texas and I'm in school
stay in school
yeah that little ball change you're
right boobie deuces fight some Bhalla oh
I'm ready turf war started turf war
about the hit of the streets of San
Andreas you guys have already seen this
there's plenty of gameplay of us plans
right we were trying to get to the
gameplay of actual CJ under on guard
this is this is what we came here
yeah Master Roshi
yeah Roshi be let's see tympani who's
the other guy he's with Pulaski yeah I
think so the other cop really yeah I
know that yeah my city guys because I
was like a little kid spammy cheat codes
all day spamming just saying everywhere
it's the same vice city was the reason
why I bought my ps2 oh really
yeah that in Kingdom Hearts I was like
okay yo screenshot that yeah yeah
actually is there a problem with that
everyone they should make Crillon writer
from sound like rider from GTA oh my god
that'd be great
we were praying for like a voice smog
swath lights nothing yet
there would be a lot of work though for
the month again they have way too much
work I'd have to come out like next year
yeah yeah he's proud of his son our CJ
father
Roshi I think if anything they should
have put like the fighting noises EJ
punching stuff or not getting hit into
then we go to the gym and GTA san
andreas and like beef up oh yeah yeah
are like box oh oh yeah there's a good
punching bag right yeah uh there's a bag
and then I think an opponent you can
like just kind of train with with yeah
best friends right here
just look at this activity not something
you do only on special occasions you
should be moving learning playing eating
and resting every day that's the way of
the turtle school this is pretty great
got the man out a dirty mags or
something om worried about right now is
once a give past this portion and start
playing piccolo I'm not gonna be able to
see see Jakes it's not good oh you're
right think of that you play this
piccolo for a while yeah I wonder if I
can run around a CJ here in this portion
yeah
expiry access Oh
[Laughter]
Oh some good times yeah sorry man just
got to go to a burger shop get some food
hurdle my gosh that's the one thing I
didn't like my cat across these
cutscenes that the voice actor in the
suit is like he got paid for that yep he
barely said anything are you skipping
over everything
no yet no they don't CJ well CJ don't
follow the damn train so I guess he's
not know we're weaving in and out of
Canon here efficient mailed you finished
this the actual game damn you max yeah I
didn't nice yeah what god I wish I could
transplant this mod into my save file oh
yeah this is PC only I think you were on
Xbox one Elcano the chat keep yeah I
remember that writer says that til we
think like when they're riding bikes
yeah yeah I'll buy something like that
tells me to bug
[Music]
roma Roma
I got finest dirty mags turtle was no
help I think he should help turtle come
on Raph I heard that the announcer like
the the narrator the American TV yeah
yeah that was recent unfortunate man
nothing pumped me up like starting the
episode that way or ending it like next
time ballsy he also did some dough yeah
I watch it on Toonami for the first time
like most kids my age yeah on Cartoon
Network
I really missed Toonami I really did
yeah they I think they like brought it
back and yeah they did yeah but I mean
it's like the old-school tsunamis right
yeah they played a lot of like anime
over the item CJ and I exist again
oh yeah he's supposed to be right there
I'm supposed to be on the right come on
CJ where you BJ see do respect respect
mission come on there we go
nice you got sri achievement i think
this is when just talking to my boy
Crillon I love that score imposed oh
yeah he's so much taller than well
Quillin sure better yeah and so was
Gohan I guess maybe that's it yeah Goku
hangs out with shorter people
yeah oh man what's been your favorite
part so far the fishing of this mod yeah
yeah the fish it was the best when you
pulled up the tail yeah like cutscene
incorporated so oh I like the Nimbus the
flying Nimbus - yeah here we go
[Laughter]
you don't wanna know that's girly
come on Ryder CJ that time in Liberty
City man made you soft bro it's like
you're fighting sweet I think
Krillin screwed up your best friend and
sweets your brother in the game is
probably like the closest relation I can
make yeah yeah cuz Ryder's your friend
big smokes our friend but they're all
stringers currently not a traitor there
you go respect mission past oh yeah Oh
his models definitely not there either
he's supposed to be behind like right
now yeah this is the way it was meant to
be played kind of like bulking out right
there on the right this looks beautiful
and polo is like what the f man polo and
the chat is freaking out yes this is
real this is great all right so I'm
sitting here excitable Eve this is the
point where I can't play go pony longer
I think for like a long while how long
like the piccolo part it's pretty long
day like training go Hana stuffs
let me let me just talk to maybe it
works for like all main characters
hopefully I'm glad you saved but yeah
maybe it'll work for piccolo two fingers
crossed it's possible although we fought
him in the beginning his shoes CJ what's
that oh man Oh your favorite part so far
I think it was the fish and the the
Fighting's funny by like flying on the
Nimbus that was so fun yeah that's so
good - alright that's fine yeah we know
what happens when do I get back to -
Goku hmm
shoot man this parts really long - well
I can see if I can try to get there real
quick like rush through this yeah let's
see all right well that's has a chat if
you want me to try a pile throughs as
fast as I can to get back to Goku or do
you want me to try just mess around and
come is with an hour yeah that'll be
what Kanna for an hour that's that's too
long I think this is the the best way to
go about it we didn't have a choice
we had to download this on Steam this
morning and none of us had an account
with savestates so we did have to start
from beginning yeah so we're let's just
power through this okay I'm just gonna
try to just imagine there's a CJ for a
second yeah
Oh
Raddatz come on talking talking smack
polo dancer number five with an extra
shoulder yeah dad Emil is crazy who
would be Big Smoke I don't know
ting whoever's left yeah who dies first
his gam-cho we all know
[Applause]
Vegeta you know what he'd probably be
like sweet like you love him you hate
him yeah he's eventually on your side I
hate this fight cuz after like you give
him everything and when you win he's
like haha he like runs away like that
was nothing nice got that quick s yeah
for st. Andreas
alright enough talk
reddit's have you seen that compilation
of how many times that first like it's
over 9000 how many times that's been
recorded there's been so many iterations
of that mostly by the same American
actor oh really
yeah but there were there were multiple
releases like oh here we go we're back
oh we get to see this cutscene with CJ
oh forgot about that he comes here oh he
gets knocked up what you picked the
wrong calm a house I'm from Liberty City
you remember me this guy's a baller he's
like trying to get CJ back yeah to the
ballers you are not grow street
[Laughter]
he's got a problem with our block yeah
he does mm-hmm some for you to step away
man telling the truth these sands are
some real bad dude these ballers he's
supposed to be on the left there no
somebody's like what show for the
cutscenes you're laughs man there's like
a cell phone on the ground you see Jay
there is protecting his family and
friends
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
lalla thank you for dropping by good day
to you to know you ain't taking my son
[Laughter]
there you go David asked in the chat
that's for you
CJ is here is the wrong neighberhood oh
yeah
[Laughter]
this is a gross treat territory man in
the wrong place
[Music]
the fighting animations look really
smooth
I think the modern spent a lot of time
on that specifically it looks like he
was meant to be in this game it's so
weird it does look this is official
Canyon now that's what's up from Grove
Street right there
[Music]
wasted
[Music]
Oh No
Yuri dipped yeah oh shoot whoa there we
go decorations
come on Bulma you knew neither of us has
what it takes to face him who he CJ's to
Introit on our own
secondhand man let's see who we talking
with a rider or sweet sweet his brother
yeah pity of riders more see who's a
traitor cuz big smoke and ryder are
traitors I don't think anyone's really a
true leader was bad so I guess yeah we
had a bad pass I still say Crillon is
sweet
he's like best brain my brother yeah
yeah and fickle is too good to be writer
I think yeah you know what rats is like
writers like walking on them tear his in
the chat grocery home at least it was
before radix after everything up it's
very true why are these stories lining
up so well I know I'm actually like
curious oh hey Alexis sorry about that
who are you trying to figure out how to
see the video cuz chats taking over
hopefully you figured that out
normally you should be able to see both
on one screen camilo ray why did I just
get myself into that mean the homies
gonna roll that real quick yeah you see
the title CJ is modded into DBZ Kakarot
any plays
Goku himself boom a break rolling out I
love this that's like our thumbnail yeah
it's so sick I wish would just like play
every cutscene yeah that was definitely
the funniest the fish was pretty funny
though okay thank thank gosh alright so
we can get through playing so good sweet
okay we don't need to play the piccolo
part yeah yeah it's a while driving
around with the homies yeah in Los
Santos
oh we can go over world oh-hoh Cloud
Strife yeah almost sounds different to
you huh yeah yep velho CJ is here GTA
Jackson pool
drive that milk truck oh god this is
there were so many mods like that can
make you like do funny stuff in GTA but
like this is like this is this is what
little Richie wanted back in the day
yeah this is it why
although the jetpack was there oh here
we go
square up with some ballers
[Laughter]
sigh bored man oh yeah we're trying to
cyborg man maybe can help us we're
trying to compare who who could be in
the DBZ world who would fill the shoes
of Big Smoke
we don't know who's like who's like good
at first but then like a traitor help us
out we don't know yeah but she does the
opposite he was bad person then turns
good so yeah and we said the same about
piccolo like he had a bad past yeah what
was it like daemon something pick I
forgot but he's good now he's great yeah
unless they're like brainwashed yeah
exactly like natural hey they gotta
dress the same way CJ yo is there a zip
clothing store around here you got y'all
shop at have a me nation trap in the
chat says what the every is this I'm
gonna read that but yeah this is this is
exactly what you're thinking of is
welcome you're welcome
stop by Burger shot real quick what's
the other this is another fast-food
place I'm sure I wish I could go in the
car the NPC's in DTA had the best voice
lines too
oh yeah was that the drug dealer guy who
hangs out on your blog freaking like oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like a name you
can respond negatively like get out of
here man man I love this so much
remember the story cuz all he did was
like stupid to goof around yeah that's
cool I mean that's generally yeah yeah
it's that's how I was a very popular way
to play yeah
your song was good though sorry it was
pretty good yeah
from what I remember I think I just
remember watching oh yeah I'm not gonna
go over there CJ takes out a big-ass
dinosaur or white dog warning you picked
the wrong house fool Oh what in the Sam
Hill is going on here yeah got him got
him all right
sick I'm out that's at no time yeah yeah
no they're just for hunting they're not
ready for fighting broke man in the chat
said it should be fat he should be fat
when he eats he's got all those funny
extra lines like when you're when you're
fat and running from cops he's like a
like slow down I can't breathe there's
like this is a bunch of stuff like that
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm gonna do rock-paper-scissors
somebody else good mission pass respects
plus main you get like a thousand
dollars yeah yeah cyborg man ball is
incoming
don't worry cyborg man we took him out
good let's go to Las mentor us all right
what san fierro is the other one that's
modeled after San Francisco oh yeah
what's funny is there was there have
been several mods of Goku in san andreas
world oh really
yeah so now the crossover is real then
the crossovers real yeah for some reason
the fans just love seeing these two
together even in like what's that game
for the ps2 there were tons of Dragon
Ball Z games on the kids to play yeah
it was one of those fighting ones and
you can mod CJ in those two oh I think
so yeah I think I've seen it these two
these two timelines just going just so
well together
a broke man says me and my boys do the
rock-paper-scissors but to the ball was
in the hood you're gonna win over this
turf remember that in the later game of
GTA like you just claim your territory
after killing some ballers like the maps
all green remember uh like this is your
hood now after you kill some ballers the
screen will just tell you this is your
hood now
that's basically where you're doing the
keeping it Grove yeah I wish you could
do graffiti oh that's a big baller
I think the equivalent of grocery would
be a common house here yeah it's like
the house they all they all stay at yeah
everyone's there all your friends are
family oh here we go
alright now their ball was battle
Wow
that was very quick getting stronger CJ
yeah yeah that's another one reaper in
the chat says there were a lot of fusion
skin mods like after fusing when people
oh it's right oh there was I think I
remember seeing a mod of like CJ fusing
would Goku I think I've seen that dude
EJ was Super Saiyan hey hey yeah I've
seen it yeah that's right what's the
other game design I know there's another
game in San Andreas the Vagos that's
what that's what we're fighting now oh
yeah they wear like all the yellow
samurai J I think just joined us he said
no goddamn way CJ has been modded into
Kakarot you're looking at it my friend I
kinda wanna play the whole game like
this I know why not how long would you
say the game is I didn't finish a very
wrong game really I mean that's cool for
DBZ fans you know yeah I mean let's just
keeping all the cutscenes like it's
smoother here than during the cutscenes
when he's like blinking in and out of I
think if they like kind of smoothed out
the mod and like to work out the kinks
like I would definitely yeah you got
sweet with you you're good yeah
no cops though that's a big factor yeah
I guess a key blaster more can henrique
says hey las Pinterest is looking
different yeah we're out here in the
hills of Las Venturas man yeah just find
some money hanging out with woozi you
know what's up you remember was e that
that blind guy who uh who runs like a
like a I count like a mob in las
pinturas but it's funny cuz he's blind
and he doesn't tell you that he's blind
told forever
yeah and the first time you meet him you
race with him in a car and he does
incredibly well I just
I object cyborg man asks is CJ in the
cutscenes he's in the in-game cutscenes
not the the cinematic ones Louie says
this is incredible Oh glad you tuned in
friends we're having a ball here you
should go back if you're watching live
like scrub back to the beginning of this
where we fish it's hilarious that
animation there's actually the fishing
animation when he got punched by Raddatz
yeah on the ground or when he was like
what when he's on the nimbus to that
breed says CJ is Opie yep got some love
from her woozy from CDA in the chat yeah
Louise he's great I love his character
he's so like humble but he's like a like
a businessman you know how long is San
Andreas if you do like nothing but the
missions I think it's like you know I'm
not even gonna guess I forget I don't
want to I don't want to misquote I think
it I don't know we watch like a long
play yeah
I don't know I can tell you how many
hours I spent playing that game but now
how much the campaign is oh my god no I
hate the bar those remote I can't even
speak as I'm so angry these are the RC
plane missions from San Andreas even you
remember those no well I remember that
there was a RC planes and by city there
were two yeah we had a bomb that
building Oh drop a little bombs in the
garbage cans it was so hard to control
dude no one's gonna believe me in chat
or anywhere but I was gonna but recently
I downloaded Vice City on the ps4 cuz I
gotta play it again yeah and I did that
mission in one try oh really
one try and I couldn't believe me and I
couldn't believe in myself I was like I
should have like screencap that like do
it [ __ ] that's not gonna believe me
thanks yeah I was like no no way like no
freaking way
you know another game that uh sort of
like brought back those memories
recently was outer wild so I was playing
that oh yes like there's like a mission
where you had to like control an RC like
little like oh great so were you raging
oh my god that's like sort of control is
getting advice to do flashbacks I don't
know I think I would hate to go back and
play those excuse me those RC missions
in San Andreas yeah it's kind of the
same thing except you're like you
control one and then you shoot them down
like there's a few missions you work
with one guy yeah and it's all about
like RC stuff it's oh so fab yep
notorious MOA and the chat says he he's
got those feels for those RC missions
but one of these up I mean if you could
do those on one try you get my respect I
don't know how I did it oh I still can't
do it for San Andreas but somehow I did
it for my city yeah and that was
legendary like that difficulty was like
memed out for how how hard it was yeah
everyone knows the Vice City RC mission
Darius and the chasis Gohan you're not
my dad
[Laughter]
Taher Z hello welcome playing a little
Kakarot with the CJ mod if he came oh my
god he's looked over the screen this is
gold villager this guy's like swole -
why is everyone I'm like what does make
our Earth's whoa they're so small
yeah well that actually this can't be
gross treecko's groceries calm down all
right yeah I'll just keep doing side
misses mission to CJ and I won't keep
going through yeah this is basically you
know uh before like maybe like 15
minutes before the end will fight
Raddatz okay right now it's we got about
a half hour left on the stream okay so
like 15 minutes we'll do some side
missions and then 15 minutes away we'll
do some Raddatz fighting Louie says we
should turn on vsync because there's
some screen tearing I thought that was
just the monitor but I think I see it
too like on the top I don't even know
that's the thing like I don't think I
have the option if not forget it but
like protip from chat there well let's
see if that worked watch it's gonna shut
down the game CJ won't work whoops
whoops whoops my fingers slip
ah trouble later now seems to be I mean
he had that I don't see the tearing
anymore yeah well yeah it's not so much
tearing for sure now he's like blinking
in and out yeah right into a fight yeah
oh damn Oh q mg skills are increased
thank you
dang I wish I could get into cars like
this though that would be so funny oh
there is a mission later and Dragonball
Z Kakarot where you can learn how to
drive really yeah you get on the same
scale but that's so far in the story I'm
still having a ball
yeah it's just so funny to see turn here
at school turn this off I'll come back
later yeah yeah this will be a vods
later yeah you gotta watch some of the
earlier cutscenes are a grade yes for
those of you who have just tuned in
either scroll back or watch this later
cuz the beginning of this was hilarious
when you go fishing with Gohan yeah it's
great there we go alright guys got a
mullet yeah
you know yo yeah take it youth there we
go there we are it's like a done closed
cut seams really yeah if you're yeah
you're right you're right
Keegan what are you guys all doing at
school watching this mm-hmm I don't
condone this I'm gonna put you on
timeout I can do that you know just
watch this later please stay in school
pay attention
okay on the way there we're gonna do
submission yeah here we go yeah for
those of you who haven't seen it yet
just whip out a tail go fishing little
feet like turned in yeah we're the first
time I saw that was like okay that fish
is ridiculously yeah although that's
probably how it was in the anime yeah
they were when they cook it it's small
so it doesn't make any sense what the
hell yeah Darius you're in the wrong
game fool CJ's a little lost but he's
good I'm sure there's some fanfiction
chat we were wondering too about what CJ
would look like a Super Saiyan form yeah
I don't think we'll get there today but
just picture it you know it's got the
hair probably the same clothes yeah it's
probably the same just the hair and the
outline oh my even this regular villager
is like buff too
yeah it's the more and more we're
playing the less it seems out of place
I'm like is
that's just CJ he belongs in this game I
mean next to the other village it would
like addressed exactly like that white
guy with like the same shirt and jeans
he's pretty much the same guy same whoa
okay there we go
oh you never got his emblem before yeah
yes look CJ you guys see he's already
been in the game yeah this is pretty
cool this is great yep just rolling out
together instead of just driving to your
destination just just fly whoa that guy
straight up look like Frankenstein yeah
I think that was a lot of references in
DBZ to like this minor thing yeah that's
so funny yeah he's an Android that's
funny then yeah make sense follow the
damn ball CJ yep huh are his fingers
stuck together again yeah in that
classic rock star way where there's a
man there's like this stuck yeah they're
fused together whoa he's like hey help
here got your back he's a gentle giant
piccolo relax
I love how right he came out of nowhere
yeah
oh you wanna beat up some dudes oh shoot
that's not a gentle giant request at all
[Music]
Big Papi J here we go again oh wow
that's pretty far actually
that's cool there were long drives in
GTA this is how it goes nature the beast
s true Big Papi J keeps going I'll take
to number nine oh my god number 45
number seven I forget the order there's
so much like I saw one video maybe like
five years ago of someone ordering that
like the equivalent of that oh and
that's become like its own like I don't
know I've since then I've seen like ten
more of those videos like doing it
realized YouTube loves to push those at
me they're like hey you watch this video
of some guy eating like so much
McDonald's yeah I dress like Big Smoke I
gotta look that up now yeah someone did
the math like he ain't like you know two
hundred thousand calories G he actually
ate it
oh I don't think I finished it
well yeah you're right I want to say her
name right Aditya
there was radio driving around with the
homies like hey rose I was more of Radio
Los Santos myself but yeah now while
flying
I missed it max what happened Oh
bugged out for a second Oh No
damn
CJ's powers unmatched
the older I got though you guys I don't
know
the more I've appreciated like those
chat radio stations on GTA san andreas
and Vice City they're just so
well-written they're so funny yeah
basically like a big middle finger drug
like American like like Oh silly we are
and petty nice got that s mission past
respect alright Chad who's your favorite
DBZ character shout it out in the chat
man you know what when I was small I
liked the look of Yamcha and his hair so
I used to be like yeah I like Yamcha
he's like my favorite and then uh yeah
we all know how that goes that made fun
of pretty hard yeah but he's so cool
though so cool yeah like I could
definitely see young shows like a
powerful there actually was
I think either a fanfiction or like a
offs offset story or something where
Yamcha was like supposed to be the most
powerful character really yeah dang it's
like quite cool like what they did with
the oh jeez what's it called like Harry
Potter one of them uh what's his name uh
uh another kid could have been just as
easily been Harry Potter yeah cuz like
it was was it geez you know I'm gonna
stop right there I'm probably
disappointing Harry Potter fans but if
you know what I'm talking about you know
but anyway after that like Yamcha yeah
he had bad fate like twice I think you
got like killed once and then and later
I think it was like GT guys like it's
like a hand through his chest from one
of the androids like he just keep dying
in the Dragon Ball yeah I forget which
series later on where he gets like the
hand pushed to his chest from one of
those old looking Androids
oh no love for Yamcha yeah
Isaac says grove street home yep I mean
it's not right yeah this is his new home
hey dog whoo max we need Yui they just
vanish this is like some Okami stuff
right here just punching some wool Oh
year awards for hitting dogs I don't
like this zero to ten
yep zeros this mod receives a zero I
gotta find some more wolf supplies now
Mario Mario is DJ I don't know yeah Bob
Jones says it wasn't an Android saga or
unless you're saying you're referring to
that for some other reason
oh that uh Ianto got killed yeah like he
grabs him by his face and then like with
the other hand like just punches a hole
in his chest
everyone's like here we go
Bob Jones asks have you read the Yamcha
Dragon Ball manga no I have not
does he is he cooler there he's much
cooler nice got him tell me more about
Bill a couple more enemies and then
we're gonna go fight Raddatz there we go
we got about 20 minutes left on stream
actually writes pretty apart really in
second form there are will the second
fight with him yeah that's a pretty damn
[Laughter]
we'll be the equivalent like those
robots just flying around just the just
thugs on the street yep except we got
the jet pack from San Andreas yeah I
love that remember you go into instead
of area 51 it's called area 69 you break
into there and you get the jet pack for
the first time and all swear to God
that's the mission and you work with the
truth that like trippy white guy was
like always on like drugs you got to do
this for me man this will change the
world and you're like alright whatever
and you go into area 69 take out like a
thousand guards and then fly out with
the jet pack mission is so cool it's a
god they make so many 69 jokes rocks are
loves to make those yeah got him
moniece in the chances ah [ __ ] here we
go again
yep that's happened like a thousand
times on the stream i love it i know you
guys are fans just like us this is why
we're doing this oh that's a cool little
like looks like a space pot just
followed and nope can't jack and do it
Oh cyborg man you're thinking of Torino
he's voiced by James Wood the other guy
the truth I forget who he's voiced by
but he looks like Willie Nelson straight
up
yep Carl remembers area 69 so just go
there like if you have the game still
area 51 in the middle of desert it's
actually called area 69 I'm not getting
the car and we started streaming 69
minutes ago man it's like the stars are
aligning all right I think it's time to
fight riots I think we've leveled up
enough
come on I'm gonna see how much I'm away
from 366 okay let me see if I can put
just a couple more enemies walnut boy I
don't have an answer for that he's
asking to gamestop store chain is dying
I mean they've always been under hot
water but I don't know what's going on
lately why what do you know oh man I
knew I pronounced your name wrong I
pronounced it like your Google assistant
ah all these all these beautiful names
from all these countries I can't do it
man
but yeah help me help me pronounce your
name right I think I said Aditya Aditya
anyway thank you for for being here
oh yeah samuel jackson was Tenpenny
that's for sure a cyborg man remembers
that that was so it was such a great
role for him it was perfect he just like
be himself he'd be like oh he played up
a crooked cop perfectly samuel l.jackson
here we go is this the fight yeah this
is the fight oh now I'm remembering the
episode yes this game is available you
can play it in Japanese I believe right
play a cyborg man ray Liotta's and he is
Tommy Vercetti we're here you picked the
wrong planet
yeah Raddatz come on bad father
no bad parenting he's not good father
truly think you stand a chance against
me you cyborg asses pick a little sweet
a sweet like the brother yeah
Carl's brother I think I was saying
Crillon might be sweet but no I that's
cool too you pick a little bean sweet it
works you know who you think it hit by
that yeah I figured out that you can use
the first
only a true villain talks [ __ ] during
the middle of a fight you nice hey
William this first place
oh you saying it's another one that
happens or what what was the second form
and just want to get real oh I was like
a second ago you were like this flighty
kind of hard but this is the fight
you're talking about yeah well easy low
ebb says sup welcome to the chat welcome
to the video god frickin oh jee loke oh
no quite the build-up to was it nappa
and Vegeta yeah if you've got a new
attack hitting up your sleeve now's the
time to use it
Goku a man I'm holding my own here yeah
I actually came up with a new technique
while I was training way to flex on us
like this is not the time I mean it's
gonna help out I'm out I am a cyborg man
says I want CJ in all games now yeah yep
this should be a global CJ mod you just
don't know when to quit
rats with a Z
alright let's got this get him CJ jewel
for the grow Erin back every black the
gunslinger welcome he says Raddatz it's
me Carl chill chill
Erin black have you been playing at all
as Joker from Mortal Kombat 11
yeah Mexico great CJ's got that shove
that little
Oh a lot of Kyoto oh is that the blue
one on the bottom
yeah oh shoot okay oh there you go you
got some back yeah I'll just keep doing
this over this is big smoke smoke I've
decided
he's got the bulletproof vest on and
everything yeah
[Music]
Alexis notice the CJ's pants situations
a little distracting it is a little
weird I mean uh gosh you probably rip
from like the PC port Oh big they're
doing their best Alexis
Aurel says i can't wait to see the CJ
transformation to a super gangster too
much yelling
that's how the anime was got to keep the
real to the sword yeah love that that
combo yeah it works out really well
we're not letting up you this is great
oh that was just like a get away from me
it wasn't nothing
I wonder who would oh jee loke we were
talking about that who we say oh jee
loke was someone in chat said it earlier
Krillin was og mo there probably be
Yamcha know who's the most annoying I
don't know
dodj sick dude that's gotta be his
finishing move look at his help
yeah you're adding I picked the wrong
house okay for the final blow damn
nicely done look sixty-nine three nice
so these ones a pre-rendered yeah you
got beat up so hard he turned back into
Goku charges up I remember that in the
anime although this is the point where I
can't play Oh after this it becomes
that's that's fine we have like oh nine
minutes or so okay and that's really a
weak point for Saiyans yeah are you
trying to kill me yeah that sound is in
San Andreas yeah that little bottles in
your big heart like CJ
come on piccolo like he's maybe doing
like a blast or anything just stepping
on them here we go
that's CJ's boy right there yeah I think
they did a good job with cuz you know
that the original kid voice actor
obviously grew up but replacing him with
that that voice actor was pretty good it
was a good brother being said
CJ you were Buster don't let go of his
tail no shouldn't it I wish this were CJ
no but yeah for those of you don't know
it doesn't work for the cinematic
cutscenes just the in-game cutscenes
goddamn Oh big
nicely done CJ mission past
no more CJ for a while I thought it went
through his chest not his head the mod
that keeps on giving head is blown off
oh my god I wonder if that'll keep I
want to see the end of this cutscene
yeah it'd be funny if it was like Goku's
body and accidentally just had CJ's head
[Laughter]
[Music]
absolutely any wish imaginable even
bringing someone back from the dead he's
gotta find him that's how I appreciate
that
you gotta help me say your name right
aditya says i can't wait for you guys to
play GTA san andreas again you to make
even the small moments look so fun
appreciate that I appreciate you being
here
Oh Gohan's voice actors a 39 year old
woman you know what that's pretty cool
really yeah that's cool Oh his head is
still gone yeah keiondre did not know
that yeah I know Goku's he no voice
actor is a right now
Goku's Japanese voice actor is a female
yeah I didn't know Gohan
all right right it's just diary he yeah
hey miss your face man it's all that
hair tune says now 1 CJ modded into the
Naruto games hey yeah oh we get to see
CJ one last time before he disappears
yay this is awful CJ say goodbye oh my
god unsettling yes how's he talking
shoulders yeah having follow the damn
train that's all we had to do right and
bye bye
rip cheese Tech precess yo this is the
uncensored version yeah it's no head
alright CJ's gonna get the little halo
oh that'd be funny to see CJ with a
little halo in heaven see can you see
what's his name the master the
sunglasses name cyborg man his corpse is
horrific yeah you know we lost his head
in the mod yeah yeah go for it see if we
can spit some heavy yeah all right
either
fine fine no open coffin for CJ
[Laughter]
we for a second no he went straight you
can't disclose that information
it's complicated we kind of died out
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah he's got to be shorter than Goku
look how high the halo is program yeah I
think it's the hair that makes oh yeah
[Laughter]
just take the quiz you'll stay you got
it how many more questions right there
this is just like testing your DBZ
knowledge even you CJ from Grove Street
oh yeah there are bugs in this but it's
the Mahdi no it's mod life yeah
Gavin yeah I don't think CJ is actually
shorter than Goku it's just all that
hair that Goku has that makes him taller
yeah and Aaron black is saying answering
to it goes oh [ __ ] I would say okay so
this one are a number it's it's so
technically actually is the right answer
is the fourth like King King Yemma is
really bad at counting so you think oh
oh
next you're sending CJ to hell okay this
is the right answer they even play the
buzzer like you got it wrong yeah
tech-free says bugs make it better as
far as I'm listening
yeah we couldn't got that headless Conte
my life
yeah play out you that's fitting because
we're parting ways here - yeah Oh King
Kai's gonna change your life Goku yeah
you already know perfect wall right flip
back here there we go thank you guys for
tuning in yeah that was hilarious
so many it was uh there was some there
were a little bit of bugs but I think
I'm like we were all talking about that
made it better
yeah but thank you guys for watching we
will be back tomorrow we stream every
day at 11 a.m. Pacific Standard Time so
thanks for tuning in thanks for being
nice and a chat we love having you guys
and we'll see you tomorrow the next one
bye
[Music]
you
you